un coup sur la tête c'est ce que
ressentent les salari des tic au fil et
les bénévoles qui encadrent cette
association chantier d'insertion
le 17 juillet dernier son cordinateur
reçoit un mail du conseil départemental
qui l'informent du versement de
subventions dans les plus brefs délais
voici la suite une semaine parce je me
permets de rappeler en 10 ans on est le
brefs délais moi ça commence à durer et
la blocage en gros je n'ai plus de
réponses et on me dit que l'argent ne
sera plus versée
le conseil départemental bloque ainsi
32000 euros du fonds social européen au
motif que l'association ne serait pas
viable financièrement son fonctionnement
est pourtant le même depuis 10 ans 70 %
de subventions 30 % de recettes propres
sans aucun problème jusque là et tico
fine emploie seize femmes en insertion
dans le secteur des services aux
entreprises comme malika qui après
plusieurs expériences professionnelles
était au chômage depuis trois ans du
coup justement sur cette association
pour nous aider à retrouver le chemin de
l'emploi
et c'est une association qui est
sérieuse qui permet justement de à la
fois de travailler d'avoir un travail
normal
on va dire quelqu'un fait un travail qui
est classique et en plus d'être à
l'écouté des salariés en termes de
sorties vers l'emploi les chiffres des
tic au fils sont parmi les meilleurs du
département
n'empêche le blocage des subventions
compromet l'existence de l'association
est d'abord le versement des salaires
moi ce que je veux c'est que les gens
soient payés on va tout faire on va tout
mettre en oeuvre
nous avons un avocat et on va régler le
problème
essayer de régler le problème et on va
tout faire ça va faire du bruit certes
mais nous on a le respect des gens
depuis deux ans département et métropole
dijonnais se livrent un bras de fer sur
les transferts de compétences entre les
deux collectivités dont la compétence
insertion l'asphyxient des tic au fils
serait tel un dommage collatéral de
cette bataille politique
contacté le président sauvadet n'a pas
répondu à notre demande d'interview